So I post a lot of, like,
finding your style after motherhood content,
personal style content, fashion content,
um, especially when it pertains to motherhood.
But I wanted to kind of put this out there
because I've been having a rough time the last couple of days,
and there's something so incredibly necessary
about wearing clothes that you feel good in.
And what you feel good in in one phase or one chapter
is not gonna be the same thing you feel good in in another chapter.
So, for example,
I have been feeling really,
really overstimulated. I have ADHD.
I also homeschool my kids.
I'm just. I'm tapped out, okay?
And I do love doing my makeup,
and I do love getting dressed,
and sometimes that can pull me out of a funk,
but sometimes it really fucking can't.
And on those days, the softest,
fluffiest,
least tight piece of clothing is going to be what I reach for.
Today it is this. Will I get dressed for the day?
I don't know yet. But right now I know I feel really,
really comfortable and safe in my cozy,
fluffy hoodie. In the early years of motherhood,
I didn't want to be perceived, okay?
I was also going through a lot of mental health issues.
I wanted to be comfortable,
and I wanted to be invisible,
and that's how I dressed. I definitely still have these feelings.
There are days when I'm either, like,
in a weird part of My cycle,
or I'm having a super, like,
aggressively neurodivergent day where I just.
I don't wanna be perceived,
in which case I usually don't even leave my house.
Because to me, and this is still how I look at it,
I'm either gonna put in 100% of the effort to do hair,
makeup, accessories,
clothes, everything.
Be fucking fit to death, right?
Dress to the nines, or there's no effort.
I don't do that. I don't do casual super well,
because to me, to me personally, um,
when I dress casual, I feel like I'm just like,
half assing getting done, if that makes sense.
Which doesn't give me the same sort of, like, confidence.
So if you were in your fluffy hoodie,
don't be perceived, be as comfortable as possible phase,
just know that even people like me,
who love getting glammed up and love getting dressed.
Hold on, babe,
one second. I have days like that too.